exercises for scissor part two
with your nage in so what it was or the
city position a lot of times you're
gonna have to come up to apply your
techniques and the way we come up is
very very important so you want to
practice coming straight up with my back
really straight and pushing myself
forward so I'm pushing from the back leg
sending myself forward I don't want my
leg to come out to the side like this
right is it bad for my knee and it's a
bad position to be in I don't want a
sloppy come up like this every time I
come up I want to practice putting my
weight dead forward right so I have a
whole lot of weight coming forward now
it would be easy for me to stand up from
this position with no further
adjustments so I'm going to practice a
series where my legs are going to come
forward every time and down notice how
my legs are coming straight out from
underneath and I'm putting weight
forward every single time so every time
I come up it's exactly as if I was going
to get up I'm bringing weight forward
and I'm ready to go when I do this my
legs aren't coming off to the sides and
I'm not just tapping my toe like this
and bringing weight forward am I like
coming straight straight up this accent
will surprise you and how much energy it
takes exercises for scissor